I'm thrilled a half to my right somebody
who I've just loved watching loved
everything about him when he was
representing my school as a basketball
player and then going on to the next
level 15 years in the NBA I can go
through all his stats but his most
important stat I think was the one steel
he had in the uncle drew movie because
he stole the whole damn show he's here
to call the Lakers and Timberwolves
tonight he is Chris Webber how are you
we talked about coming we did and now
you are a man you urge they don't want
to comment I really really old me tell
you how I think he did just a little
while ago he called it yeah you know
what he means to people like me from New
York City oh yeah yeah and even the guys
like myself like I always tell him I'm
like you know cuz I do his imitations of
him when he's not around oh I don't know
how it is bad I'm a bad imitation I like
being a bad imitation as long as you
know what do you want to talk about
tonight you want to talk about how
Sacramento Kings were terrible but you
want to dog the Lakers or you know I'm a
terrible God but when I'm talking to him
and his voice is pretty funny to me
especially because he hates it and so
yes he's the best to work with like I
was blessed at turning my first guy I
got to work with was Dick's doctor and
so here I am I know his voice I actually
you know how it is when you're young you
think the commentators are the reason
why your team wins or loses yes you know
and so growing up oh I hates dick
Stockton's cuz every Celtic game will
come oh I don't like Marr because every
game is so getting to work with these
guys and really getting schooled when
I'm going through the school of hard
knocks with them how they like things
and be professional in this I need to
know this this that it was just the best
thing so Turner really helped me by
putting the vets around me and and
keeping a safety net up under me till I
die got my legs alternate is a great job
in taking guys or gals I'm doing a
Candace Parker yeah this is a great
right so taking athletes off of the
court and has surrounding them with the
right producing and talent to make sure
that you guys succeed and gals succeed
yeah you know Marv though I mean look
I'm very
with what I do for a living and I bless
I'm blessed every day and I don't I'm
not jaded and Marv's a perfect example
you telling me Chris Webber that he says
hello to me
I mean that that just made my day no
this is Maher this is the guy who I grew
up I steal from him every day and I
sometimes can come across sounding like
him a little bit you know my imitation
of Marv though Mike if you don't mind L
to fo it works best with the NBA on on
NBC theme whenever I hear this so you
actually got a whole another
championship trying to Karl Malone
Patrick Ewing you know the weather it's
a balmy 72 degrees now I do all my prep
one like an iPad where I can write
things down with this pen and stuff and
I have my papers but Marv I don't know
how he does it he has literally a
hundred papers and anything I say I
tested him in games before I feel like
there's such a such mom but his mom is
not written any information most of us
in his head or he hasn't in some type of
crazy notes that he's had but his
context like you know how we all get
into these fun arguments that no one
will ever win who's the best dish who
was the best I'm sure he has a context
of that goes so far back and say well
Chris you know tiny Archibald scissors
I'm like okay I'll shut up right now
Pete Maravich once told me
you re like I said you're blessed and
you're here tonight for the Lakers and
the Timberwolves now you when you were
on the show of many times prior to the
season you said this Lakers team is not
a playoff team now kill me for well hold
on a second what we didn't see coming
was was LeBron missing a month I mean as
of tomorrow it will be a month since
Christmas Day when he he hurt himself by
now you giving me this look from a
production meeting I have notes in my
phone I can pull them out but the Lakers
still the whole thing I was saying was
that they don't have any shooters and if
you look at they're shooting from spots
they're xxx I'm probably one or two off
because I'm not looking for their 30th
and free throws 30th and jump shots 30th
and threes they have no shooters like
even when LeBron was in Miami who did he
have when the best shooters ever in
Rhode Island then you have to look at
where my boy Shane Battier did on Mike
Miller I think eight threes in a row
he's always had shooters around them
because he was a facilitator when he
doesn't have shooters around how can you
be the best you can be he's having a
great season it's not about him but I do
think it's about the talent that you
have around him and I think that if you
win one championship in four years
that's the story so this year really
doesn't matter in the narrative to me
but to fans I understand because if it
was me I'd tell them to shut it down
right now LeBron James would not no
place in the last nine years I have
played more minutes than he has no one
has had the body of work on the all-star
games done what they've done in the
summer and he's been a nine straight
finals right so what if he has to work
harder this year then he's had to work
to get to any final and they get this F
seat and lose in four games you happy
with that that he's not rested and
you're still trying to win one
championship I mean what is it a
championship or one game at home at the
Staples Center it's whatever you want if
you feel like we want to see him in the
playoffs at the Staples Center we're
gonna lose these two games he's gonna do
it then okay if you want to see him win
the championship why wouldn't you rest
him he's never had rest in the last nine
years so you want him to work harder
this year to be a last playoff seat
tired then you would him rest and come
back next year this groin injury is no
joke
he's 30-something years old never barely
been hurt before
I just don't know what this season means
if you're trying to win a championship
well I could say that about the entire
NBA though right no no no because
everybody isn't have the same narrative
they don't have the greatest player on
their team with their four year window
everyone else is planning to get better
plan for experience in the play I was
planning to see how they'll be next year
some of these guys never even want to
playoff round so with him is different I
mean what why wouldn't getting
experience for Kuzma in the playoffs or
experience for Lanza when he comes back
or Brandon Ingram or making it seem like
some of these guys if they do perform
well even for a game or to say against
the top-seeded Golden State Warriors
wouldn't be more valuable and a
sign-and-trade to actually pull
something off to get the championship
here so you want to get them two games
of experience entire LeBron out so he
comes in next year tired like they are
two games experience and they might be
traded know so that experience might not
even be you might not even use that
experience well Chris Webber I'm not I'm
not sitting here saying you're making no
sense okay let's put that I'm making no
sense no no no you are making a ton of
sense it's just not it's not it's not
real life possibility I don't think by
that I mean how do you is a Laker
organization
sell that you don't do the fan base here
very honestly you shouldn't care because
the fans want a championship so
listening the fans like some teams do
the teams that listen to fans never win
period the teams are listen the fans
never win I want the line is designed
this guy they wouldn't win if it they
never win and so if my goal is a
championship and for you plus let me
just say this if LeBron is out another
two weeks we don't have to have this
conversation no more then he'll just sit
it out no you guys would be so far out
the playoff race you're out the playoffs
now if the Brawn doesn't come back and
you're six games out to playoffs you
have the third toughest schedule the
rest of the way in the NBA so that means
the Browns gonna have to play as many
minutes as hard we're talking about hard
and getting tired right and LeBron has
had twice than minutes in his career
that heart in his head but nobody's
worried about LeBron getting tired what
do you think magic if you
and he sat down before the game tonight
just you find him in the crowd and you
say this to him and there's no
microphones on what do you think he says
and there's a full disclosure I've said
this to people in organizations I've
said this to people I mean this no okay
so and can you probably can you reveal
what they're really say you know we're
not giving up we're working hard sure
but if if he can't play he can't play
and if he can't play it's no playoffs if
LeBron misses if LeBron misses six more
games which he probably won't but if he
misses six more games in this run
playoffs are over so then let's play
this out this is fantastic Chris Webber
here on the Rich Eisen show I'm getting
killed on Instagram right I'm out on all
the Twitterverse I know you just hate
the Lakers you don't want them I may
hate the Lakers but I'm just being
honest which is maybe the most honest
thing anybody could say in this social
media world where everybody accuses
wrongly that you hate my team you do in
fact 8:13 I hate them with a love that
you can only I know that about someone
you hate somebody who also grew up in
the in the Detroit area with the bad
boys and all that I understand what
imagine I'm the biggest magic fan in the
world who is it so so now let's let's
play this out so then let's just say
LeBron doesn't come back let's play out
the Chris that that pálinka and and and
magic and LeBron rich Paul his agent
they all get together because let's
believe if we're gonna keep it real
doctors say it's iffy here okay you
could hurt you could hurt yourself you
could come back we could see what we
could do six games let's say that guess
six games from now let's say they say
you know what Chris Webber is brilliant
and he's four he's got the foresight
what happens in July
clearly Luke's not coming back right he
takes the fall for this huge what 15
game under 500 season potentially he may
take the fall in the next week wasn't it
rumblings that he was going to get fired
that's true so what happens though when
it's now time I hey everybody's got to
come to Los Angeles and help LeBron win
which you know
the bleach reports you already know I
know what I'm saying though is it
doesn't it make it less attractive that
the Lakers missed out that LeBron
couldn't make it through right LeBron is
never less attractive okay you're
looking at me like I'm crazy I'm fans
what happened two years ago the Lakers
people can't tell me the Lakers roster
two years ago I think we have short
memories I think fans have short
memories I have a short memory I'm going
to be screaming the Lions can win the
Super Bowl next year it's just what we
do at the end of the season and I think
that having LeBron be healthy that's all
I'm saying is it's about having LeBron
be his healthier self and I think that
he's susceptible to injuring himself
again the groin injury is very serious
and if he has to miss games if he is not
healthy and he misses the next six games
I seriously would think about it because
he's just gonna be fighting back
fighting back trying to make it and it's
still no guarantee that they'll make the
playoffs they have to make some big
moves and what if you get a draft pick
what if you're the next Boston you put
all these players together so I just I
just don't think the playoffs is as
important in year one as winning the
championship and in order to win a
championship you're gonna need a healthy
LeBron and I think you need to weigh
that as opposed to the expectations of
the first year with this guy I also
think you need the Warriors to break up
so I want to take a break and we'll have
we'll have a conversation of what the
Warriors look like right now I do want
to hit Harden with you and just so much
more I'm so thrilled that you hear this
Webber is here more with c-webb when we
come back on the Rich Eisen show Chris
Webber who is in town with Marv Albert
to call the Lakers and Timberwolves
tonight on the NBA on TNT right back
here on the show what do you make of
hardens current stretch he's off the
hook right now look how he's just such a
great shot maker you know I've never
seen anyone and the game has changed so
you you couldn't have seen anyone in the
last before the last 10 years because
guys like Bert were not allowed to shoot
three threes again
Ray Allen wasn't allowed to shoot
consistently on the fast-break he had to
run at the correct way at that time and
lay it up so we've never seen this type
of play before but his ball handling him
off the pick-and-roll where guys have to
make a decision to go over
or under and then his passing to a guy
like capella and capella finishing
inside so it's almost like the post I
really been trying to do this little
breakdown for MBA TV in my mind where
his game is so ugly meaning the style of
play but if you look at it as like
reposting I catch it in the post I
thought it back out to you throw it into
me and I'm posting up that's him at the
top of the key and when talking to coach
Dan Tony he says you find me a better
play than him at the top of the key any
better playing I'll run it and I don't
know if I can find you find him you
can't find a better play than what he
then what he's doing is so you know
people say do you would you want to play
with him would you not the type of
player I am if I'm gonna pick him role
and I know if you pass to me I can shoot
and I can do all that I would want to
play with them other guys that maybe
don't touch the ball as much and waiting
in different places
I don't know how fun it would be to play
in that system say yeah that was the
question Brockman you wanted to ask
right over before doesn't seem like this
would be all that fun to just stand
around for 20 seconds and watch him
dribble over at between his legs and
then shoot a step back yeah but PJ
Tucker would he be this valuable in the
other team no probably not but he's also
a great rebounder and defender on both
ends and he's also one of the best
corner shooters so he just waits in the
corner for him it's almost like you're
just waiting for your play if you don't
touch it this time it's okay what I what
I do like about is like to try and go
offense what it did was it put a leash
on players he said you can only go here
you can only go here that was the
brilliance of the triangle offense
everybody couldn't shoot and dribble ten
times like on some teams it doesn't
matter how well you score you get the
same freedom as other guys and that's
terrible coaching you we shouldn't get
the same freedom if I can do more than
you you should keep the ball in your
place and I think that hard and though
the play is ugly is sufficient because
if anyone's gonna make a mistake it's
him and his passing is just showing and
incredible if you really think about it
the little layups and flips that he does
and things like that day I don't know
it's better to have him pass the ball
cut through the other side get it to
Chris Paul dribble back around I mean
you know averaging eight assists a game
but are we getting Eric Gordon's full
potential are we seeing what he could
really do yeah if air Gordon was on if
air Gordon was on a
the team and not to talk bad about but
it would be like Bledsoe okay I mean
it's we're not talking about a super
super starter he's not getting the ball
to it's no one on his team is no one on
his team that can carry a team well I
guess it all comes down to a Chris is
houses gonna beat the Warriors right
some would say last year they beat the
warrior I know that I know that would
say you only get one chance I mean it
was it was right there for the taking we
all know Chris Paul got hurt seems to me
though the Warriors with boogy boogy in
the first 12 minutes I saw it looks like
he was playing with him for 12 years and
he's em everyone's wondering in a way
how's this gonna work it looks like it
works perfectly it looks like he can he
can dish he can shoot he can rebound he
can post up he can create all sorts of
problems when you're spotting up
shooters like they have right it seems
like that this is a righted ship if at
all was on a reef it looks like it's
there for the taking again Chris yeah
after the little beef between Durant and
Andrea I think he's been the perfect
confusing them energy like they love
playing with them I know a lot of people
in the media like how is this gonna work
it's gonna work great these guys hang
out in the summer they want to play with
each other they asked him to come to the
team he's not gonna rock the boat
whether it's not rock the boat because
it's all those guys and he doesn't want
to be ostracized by them or locker room
or as the fact he's playing for money in
the contract and if you don't do well in
this locker room like what locker room
are you gonna do well and so they have
everything going for him and the biggest
thing is this dude averaged 27 13 and
five-and-a-half assists on the team that
leads the number one team go to state in
assists at 30 a game he loves passing so
his screens the other night for Thompson
to get old like you have to play within
the culture and when he gets hot they're
gonna go to him just like they go to
curry Durant or Thompson so they know
they're the best individual players and
collectively they can be the best thing
it's gonna be tough to stop them so
who's gonna who's gonna be the one that
does I mean give me would you say it's
in the East not in the West I know
you're laughing but I'm you who's gonna
who's gonna beat them seven games right
now I mean
it's the Nuggets maybe the Thunder gets
it together me honest
the Raptors obviously the Pacers took a
huge blow down that's most of all deeper
the team so I don't really see anyone
taking him down now haven't the last
four or five years but the team I really
like and and I really like them is
Toronto they're good and so what do you
like about it they have the best bench
in basketball they also have height and
lint siakam those guys can all play and
switch together so now you have siakam
Kauai six seven switching out you have
Lowry at the point guard and even he
doesn't have to have the pressure of the
final of the last playoffs he just needs
to facilitate the big fellas inside
Ibaka
they have they can play four or five
different lineups they can go big and
then go small they like to run they're
not your normal East Coast team that
doesn't score and they get after you and
I want to say they beat the Warriors I'm
not sure good okay okay uh uh Hawaii in
in Oakland
I like their team and I'm telling you
you can't first of all you can't check
any guy in the league did you just can't
you just have to play your best and hope
they miss but they have guys that can
maybe bother Durant a little bit because
he's the same size it's not like when
Durant was playing against Houston and
they were switching Chris Paul's on and
that's shooting over a chair in the
drill so now they have guys that
actually can put a hand in the face and
other things that maybe can deter him
from shooting or maybe cause my miss but
I just like the team I like the
structure and they play Chris Webber
here on the Rich Eisen show alright
let's switch gears a little bit what do
you think is I on what do you think and
when you see him play manchild manchild
oh just manchild that term has been used
since I've been way before and younger
but since I can remember when I was
gentle and maybe say that about and he's
the first person I didn't like no that's
that's a man-child yeah yeah super
athletic he is all that it looks like
right now
I'm gonna share with you what I have set
into this microphone Chris Weber that
seeing coach K go all in on the young
freshmen like say Steve Fisher did back
in the day with you Jalen and the rest
of the Fab five seeing this current
Michigan team a team right where
beelines got everybody positioned and
they've got some
great veteran players okay at the point
I love what Matthews is doing okay
seeing now Coach K go all in on the
young kids only to have Michigan stand
in their way just to run it back back to
the future oh gosh I'm so all in for
that you know be funny uh I wouldn't it
I love Coach K it is funny to see him
embrace these young guys it's even more
funny to hear him make excuses for them
in interviews hmm that we weren't
allowed to have 25 years what do you
mean by that well I think that Christian
Laettner in my lifetime is the greatest
college player of all time period after
Kareem
Walton it to me is it's not a question
and we're going up against the team they
beat UNLV my favorite team ever the year
before you know he was a pro team they
beat you an LV that was an
accomplishment I so for us to go up
against the team that beat UNLV and it
was you know statements like well it's a
team they're not just freshmen or they
can grow up they'll learn or you know
and now he's like wow guys got to learn
how to play together we're young you
know things that are true but it's just
funny here in the champion Coach K say
that now but I love the fact that he's
embracing it and I love the fact that
he's helping these young kids because I
want kids that maybe go out and one or
two years to have experience to have a
great coach like that because in the
past you were either lucky to have a
coach Fisher or you went to a place that
you knew was going to be a stop you
maybe didn't get much coaching and then
it affected your career in the pros and
I think these kids are definitely gonna
be better off having Coach K in their
life but it would be funny if it comes
down to that and you know it I told
someone the beginning of the year said I
could see that happening and that that
would be something
gosh that would just be because I'm
still pissed I'm still pissed I'm not
that I mean that Michigan the Fab five
right there and yeah and Duke yeah
denied yeah yeah they were a bad bunch
of boys though you know we were so bad
we were some bad men ourselves and when
I look at you know you think about the
career some of these guys had and what
they did you know you're never proud of
losing
anyone but remember in the scouting
report and all the stuff that they had
done back then the players they had you
know that was that was a hell of a team
to me you know that Duke team is is one
of the best college teams we've seen do
you see any young kids today recognize
what you and the rest of the Fab Five
had blazed the trail to you did you
think that folks understand what the Fab
Five Michigan Wolverines stood for and
created because it seems like there's a
ton of imitators now when at the time
you got so much crap I remember cutting
our hair ball and the commentator said
we were tux part of the reason why I
love being the commentator is because
how the narrative that was on us so when
I do college games I know what it's like
for that family to sit there and watch
their son and they're praying being
nervous so I know what it's like the
guys to be emotional or they're up 30
points in the walk-on gets in the game
you know all those wonderful moments the
team moments is so that's really why I
like doing college because I can do that
because the commentators in our time
they weren't right you know they didn't
know much about other cultures it wasn't
as diverse and so it was easy to cast
aspersions or to say that these people
are like this and you really don't know
but you're judging our body language and
you're making judges on the content of
our character howdy language how are you
handling that at the time Oh at the time
we loved it we bring it on more you know
at the time you know eight anybody 18 is
against the world it's like the world is
against us like that's what we need it
we were all from a poor city we were all
from friends and families that are
struggling people that like we knew we
were their hope on Saturdays we knew
what we were bringing to the table for
our family and friends so we embraced it
I mean and and that's what I hope that
the young kids take with them is that
take everything with a grain of salt the
praise and the criticism and if anything
use it all as energy to have something
to fight against and a lot of kids come
up and they do give us love they do oh
yeah or where there where yeah probably
through their dad you know that you know
you know what I mean but but
cuz it's just amazing Chris Chris Weber
here on the Rich Eisen show I mean
you've got the number four up the Jersey
up there Brockman or the Michigan number
four from the Fab five
just seeing now it's just if you don't
have a one-and-done team you don't have
much of a shot which is why what Bilan
is doing in michigan is just it's an
outlier yeah and this year as opposed to
beeline building a team that then comes
out and becomes a behemoth in March this
year Michigan started seventeen and all
I'm telling you it's these top six teams
it's gonna be something man I mean
basketball this year in college is
really good especially like you said how
beeline teaches the game penetration
kick-out draw he has guys that can play
in all different type of positions so
it's it's gonna be good I would caution
though because college basketball is
real and so they know we can go 17 and
on and they know we could lose the first
game of the tournament and so that's the
wonderful balance of basketball is like
okay we've done that but so what what do
we do tomorrow right you're your
honorary captain see this year we talked
about it you don't have to call him
right after what how about now you're a
couple months removed how is this
sitting with you in terms of you and Ann
Arbor and everything and everything it's
it's uh it's great I call coach Harbaugh
at the indices and give him wisdom
congratulations
a couple of guys off the team made a
relationship with and hopefully I can do
them right by mentor I love the fact
that I went back there we still have
scholarships at the University since my
time of leaving so right now I'm just
really happy that I got a chance to go
back as far as another step or something
I'm enjoying my kids right now and
trying to get through the rest of the
season okay but that was the hopefully
the first step but it was initiated
through coach Harbaugh and I really
appreciate him for that because if not
it would not have happened do you have
any contact with b-line at all or no I
don't I called coach I don't know I
called coach when he had a procedure and
just that's wrong I was thinking about
him but besides that is I don't know how
much it is for me and him to talk about
it's really between me and him and the
school was like he wasn't there so I
it's it's unfortunate but my
relationship was not with him I went to
the University
Michigan right so but I mean you
represented the basketball team and so
the school should have that talk not the
basketball coach that wasn't there it
has nothing to do with it it's a lot to
talk about and hopefully next time when
my book comes out you'll allow me in the
book and I we can talk for hours so
you're putting this all in a book
essentially you're um I don't know I may
write the book and never put it out okay
I don't know it just depends on my mood
but I'm not gonna circumvent a
conversation that needs to be between me
and the school because the basketball
coaches they're like what what does that
have to do with it no I know I mean no
no I'm not saying that this means to the
I totally understand I mean Harbaugh
wasn't there either but he did reach out
and again on behalf of everybody I'll
say I'm in behalf of everybody roots for
the Wolverines I mean you and the fold
you know would be monumental just to be
I'm not the one that told me I couldn't
go mm-hmm so you tell me I can't come
over your house but then you want me to
come over your house and say hey I'm
here I mean come on like this no I hear
you so so he serves athletic director
there's a smoker there man come on em
okay and the full disclosure I've talked
to the athletic department mmm you know
everybody just you know wanted it's just
it's unfair to put coach b-line in that
position I really believe that he has
nothing to do with anything he does not
know me mmm but you're open having a
conversation is what you're saying I've
been open to having a conversation
and yeah I've been open to having a
conversation we'll see what happens and
we see and it hopefully started with the
call I got or tens of calls I got from
the coach all about saying this year
this year no next year next year and so
I thank him for his patience and you
know we'll see what happens okay Chris
Webber here on the Rich Eisen show and
then obviously you got the broadcasting
your your twins or how old okay oh you
said ah 20 months I'm in a month County
now so almost two years of my boy man is
scary
he looks like he's like four and a half
years old okay he's like 14 I got by I'm
Suzy grows out in the next day I'm sure
every parent goes through that for sure
but
I'm you know both again you and I have
Michigan ties
I'm not Chris Webber well you know so my
kids do grow out of shoes but not nearly
damn that new things about babies man
but it is awesome before I came out of
town like I told my wife I don't know
how much longer I'm gonna do this
because my daughter looked up and was
like I miss you daddy was the first time
I heard miss you and she's looking at me
like killed me to leave I know you know
I thought my daughter will do that too
Oh she'll look at me you know it's
whenever it's time for me to go on the
bag comes out it's bad news no now when
I pull the bat is so funny so now I have
to play with them and kiss them and
distract them and just run and don't
show your Bacchus now they see the bag
coming and it's our title now you love
me cuz you know daddies don't get
appreciated I wake up no more give me a
kiss like mama but now they're hugging
and kissing me like oh you about to
leave I'm like okay you to start all
right well you're great at it
you really are I mean Turner's not just
gonna sit you next to Marv Albert just
because of anything but you're really
really great at it your phone ringing
after uncle drew but for more that stuff
or what yeah yeah it wrong and hopefully
you you know do some more stuff but uh
you know as guys like you
George blaha like you know when you're
watching and you know even if it's CNN
or Fox I'll watch you know how guys get
in and out of transition you know you
study for this you've you've been in
this a long time I mean how Michigan you
would you know you've been doing this
and so guys like myself you know I I
have to catch up by watching you know
and I'm not just saying it's watching
the best do it and and just seeing what
the professional framework is and then
inserting myself and and that's what I
think that I've learnt the best of the
guys do they have a template very
professional but if you weren't rich
really none of this at work you just be
a professional hack sitting in front you
know we watch because of you and so I
just try to make sure I can put all that
and present it but I think I think
really everybody all the suits are
turning because they really make it I
don't miss basketball because it's the
locker room that you really miss after
and we get that at turneth well that's
the one thing that we're trying to do is
as always at the NFL Network Chris is
when we started was to try and create as
many real conversations because that's
what fans want to know they want to know
what you're really saying we were really
thinking as an athlete or a general
manager or a team owner or something
like that
and you know when there's real
conversation when urban and Kurt Warner
and when Marshall Faulk and Sapp and
Dion
I mean Dion Oh only knows one style of
conversation that's real yeah NBA and on
Turner's that all the time you know kg
creating an area of 21 for him and again
like I said I think Candace Parker is
fantastic and what you are doing the
players only stuff on NBA TV I mean and
hear the stories from Kevin McHale I
tell Kevin I wish I just had a camera
just for when when when the show goes
off to hear his stories he's the best
storyteller they're not safe for workers
I've already watch you saying they're
not safe for workers I just don't have
anything to do at work like he might
just tell you one time he was hunting in
Montana and something happen you know
he's just he's just the front he might
be the funniest guy I've ever met
oh my god Kevin McHale it's not curry
seriously if it if it means being in a
great movie damn right the world that
was funny Van Gundy said that the other
day when they had a they had a a promo
for Celtics and warriors he said it's
the world as flat versus the
moon-landing never happened can you talk
some sense into these kids see where boy
come on
this is crazy but you know like it's
crazy but I was like why is everybody
like why would you it was like he's
messing up education like I would tell
like my kid like carries a great
basketball player you don't listen to
him for B reason like why are we giving
him this much you know Creed is it's
like yeah he went to Duke I mean he went
to Duke for seven games oh oh man I just
again a camp I can't I mean could you
imagine it all comes down to dukes
freshmen versus a Michigan team in the
finals and the Duke freshman freshman
freshman freshman team goes down to
Michigan I'm serious like I just oh I am
so only an hour God like I'm a sinister
granite
napkin tucked in I got my knife in my
fork and I am ready to feed ya oh that
would be speed now there's the eye but
the problem is is there's a Virginia
there's a Gonzaga there's a Tennessee
just for starters yeah and Michigan
State but they have a beaten Michigan in
a couple years
no not in football and hockey nothing
bill hockey at least there's something
we could crow about right there hey
great to see you sir
thank you early it's one of my favorite
scene with Sue's - she always loves
seeing you and without games whatever
and so you the man please come back any
time Chris Webber Chris Webber here on
the Rich Eisen show at real course
somebody sitting on Twitter with Chris
rubber is that what it is you're yes
like 6 followers anyone like a billion
dollars for the name keep it real very
good at real Chris Webber on Twitter
watch him with Marv tonight from from
here in Los Angeles the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience